thousands of people in Pennsylvania
expressing concerns about the safety of
a multi-billion dollar gas pipeline
being constructed across the state the
Mariner East two pipeline will transport
natural gas liquids from a Shale region
in western Pennsylvania to an industrial
complex near Philadelphia that is more
than 350 miles the oil company behind
the massive project says it will add
billions of dollars to the economy and
create hundreds of jobs Don Dahler is in
Exton Pennsylvania where some residents
say the payoff isn't worth the risk
Don good morning good morning as you can
see the Mariner east to pipeline runs
right through town and through some of
the most densely populated parts of the
state eventually it will carry liquid
natural gas to a shipping terminal where
it will be exported overseas pipelines
are nothing new to this area but many of
the residents who live around here say
the construction of this one is
continuing without due consideration of
the risk the sheer scale of the Mariner
east to pipeline is best viewed from
above where a path has been carved into
the landscape of Chester County
Pennsylvania just over 30 miles west of
Philadelphia where the drill site is
that used to be covered in beautiful
mature big trees Virginia Kerslake and
David mano are concerned neighbors this
is what is coming out of my well did
they tell you what this what the
chemicals are in this this isn't
bentonite clay which is what they used
to lubricate the drill bit what is your
worst-case scenario an explosion if
there were to be a leak in the pipeline
the gas escapes it goes back into its
gaseous state it's odorless its
colorless as long as it goes undetected
it's just waiting for an ignition source
to set it off and if it explodes the
blast zone is anywhere from a thousand
to two thousand feet the 2.5 billion
dollar mariner east to pipeline is being
built alongside an older smaller
pipeline called Mariner East one it will
transport liquid forms of ethane butane
and propane across the full width of
this
date to a refinery complex at Marcus
Hook once completed Sunoco has plans to
add an additional pipeline altogether
it's estimated the pipelines could
transport up to 675 thousand barrels
each day according to a recent report
paid for by Sunoco the project will add
as much as nine billion dollars to the
region's economy and add hundreds of
construction and permanent jobs there's
no amount of money there's no number of
jobs that is worth putting all these
lives at risk but they say they're not
putting your lives at risk
sure of course they say that both
residents point to an independent risk
analysis funded by a group of private
citizens it concluded that a leak of
highly pressurized liquid gas could
result in a flammable vapor cloud that
could spread up to 1,800 feet within
three minutes burning anyone within 700
feet you'd have to evacuate on foot
because you can't start a vehicle you
can't even use your cell phone to call
for help because those things can set
off the gas so it's an impossible task
first responders can't build emergency
response plans we can't prepare for this
Rebecca Brittain a mother of two worries
about the safety of her family the best
I can do prepare for this risk is to
leave my kids shoes by the door so we
can run up win on foot a half a mile in
the event of a leak that's an
unreasonable amount of risk to ask my
family to take in a statement to CBS
this morning Sunoco said the pipeline
project was thoroughly vetted over the
past five years by the appropriate
federal state and local agencies and
that the company has trained more than
2,300 first responders since 2013 adding
that all are prepared to handle any
issues involving Mariner East - or any
other pipeline earlier this month the
Pennsylvania Department of Environmental
Protection indefinitely suspended work
on the pipeline for among other things
allowing the unauthorized discharge of
industrial wastes and failing to perform
work according to permit specifications
over 6,000 people have now signed a
petition asking the governor to take a
closer
look at the pipeline's potential risks
Pennsylvania Senator Tom McGarrigle said
that while the pipeline is safe the
concerns of some citizens may have been
overlooked
I think the gas companies were they
missed a boat they didn't do enough
education they needed to meet with these
neighbors and just not go ahead with
construction from now on they need to
sit down with these neighbors and
explain everything a spokesman for the
governor's office tell CBS News that the
suspension of construction will continue
until Sunoco satisfies the DEP s demands
as for that risk assessment that the
residents are asking for there is no
commitment yet from the state Nora
Don thank you it's really incredible to
see just those pipes in your backyard
really puts it in perspective and
reasonable to understand why they might
be concerned yeah vetted with everybody
jeff is usually except for the neighbors
you know they might want to weigh in on
that